[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لي فانا بادره تتعلق بما مررت به
تصيل الطفوله في فيتنام بالالام والمشاعر
الفيضان نحو الاطفال لكن كل تلك المشاعر
والالام عادت من جديد مؤخرا في الحرب على
اوكرانيا وقد شعرت بسعاده غامره جدا
للفرصه التي فتحت بزيارتين الاولى الى فيس
اوفيا في بولندا والاخرى الى اوروبا
لمرافقه اللاجئين الاوكرانيين الى كندا
لقد كنت من يقف في مدخل الطائره للترحيب
بهم وهم يدخلونها فرارا من الحرب لكنني
كنت على وشك انهيار كل ما ارى رضيعا او
طفلا صغيرا مع والديه لاجئين وهو يدخل
الطائره كانوا اطفال صغار وبنات كان
يتعاين عليه ان احبس دموعي لانني مررت
بنفسي ما مر به الفرار من الفوضى والحرب
لكن الان في موقع يسمح لي بمنحه من الامل
هذا جزء من مبادره لقد كنت احرص على ان
اقول لهم لا تستسلموا ولا تتخلوا عن الامل
فالناس تحبكم
[موسيقى]
نعم عندما يتعرف الشخص اللي ماساه في انه
يستقبلها اولا بالغضب وانا واحده من هؤلاء
لم اكن اعرف في البدايه كيف اتعامل مع
الصوره كنت سجينه في سؤال لماذا انا
ولماذا استمر بالمعاناه لكن الان تصالحتم
على تلك الصوره مع جسدي مثل ما هو لم تعد
بالنسبه لي صوره عن رعب الحرب بقدر ما هي
سفينه السلام لم تعد تظهر البربريه لانني
اود ان اتحدث عن الحب ان اجسد المغفره لم
تعد تلك الصوره تتحدث عن الموت بل انها
تظهر الحياه
[موسيقى]